who's more annoying listen or Midna
Midna no Midna
turns into a beautiful lady as not
annoying to me this is versus the
GameSpot show that pits your favorite
games consoles franchises and hot-button
issues against each other this week
we've got a wolf off as we pit Zelda
clone
Okami against the real thing Zelda
Twilight Princess fighting for a commie
is Lucy James who was such a fan of the
game she owns an original Japanese copy
and argue in the case of Twilight
Princess is big old softy bill who could
be seen here getting a little too close
to his wolf link amiibo each are going
to argue the corner for their game over
the course of three rounds with the
overall winner being decided by you the
wonderful viewers last week's debate to
figure out the best worst and weirdest
film to game tie-in saw you people agree
with Oscar over me to the tune of 61% of
the vote I won't hold it against you but
to vote who you think argue their case
better on this episode we're going to be
throwing up a clickable poll right here
on YouTube
right enough for me let's get into the
debate
[Music]
well a commie is being released again
this is actually an OG Japanese copy
nice ps2 oh it's cool okay my 2006 yeah
now it's coming to switch so we thought
for this week's episode of vs. you're a
big Zelda fan we thought we'd square it
off against it's a Zelda like game yes
there it takes a lot of these L DNA well
so what better Zelda game to compare it
to than the one we actually play as a
body ball one with a wolf yeah so should
we cook off yes we see what the first
topic is combat combat I like that sound
fake mother combats oh okay Twilight
Princess has classic Zelda combat which
was sort of defined I think for 3d Zelda
games in Ocarina and has the same
lock-on targeting system jumping sword
combat using your shield and originally
when this came out on the Wii and also
had motion controls which was was the
first I guess big game to demonstrate
motion controls when we and and it
worked really well like shooting arrows
from horseback just worked but pointing
at the screen well obviously this came
out on GameCube as well and later on we
use an HD version without any motion
controls or without all of the mission
controls and it still works that combat
is really satisfying and it also
introduced some cool like special moves
like there's the helm splitter where you
sort of jump over your enemy smash them
in the head or you can sort of roll
behind them and do like a backstab sort
of thing and the items you can pick up
like obviously classic Zelda you are
going through dungeons collecting new
items like the claw shot like the
boomerang with a bow and arrow there is
a big spiky ball on a chain which you
just throw her enemies and batter them
which keeps things fresh and you as you
go through the game you're constantly
picking up new ways to fight enemies and
then that's just as link and then you
can transform into a wolf and with Midna
on your back you can do this thing where
you target multiple enemies and then
like I could kill them in quick
succession but for me that's why toilet
princess
combats really satisfied so for me
obviously in economy you play as I'm
exactly army who's well the whole time
okay
amy has fun like a reflector on her back
but you can also have a sword and you
can also hit people with basically they
called rosary the rosary beads so
basically you just saw with people okay
well you whip the demons so there's that
element of it where it's basically like
button mashing but then the whole
gimmick if you want to call it that app
economy like the gameplay thing that
they really focused on is there because
Amy is a son she's forgotten the son she
can use her tail as a celestial brush
and you can use her tail to interact
with the environment that way and draw
on the game and where that really shines
I think is in combat because obviously
use it for puzzle solving so like
there's a crack in a war you can drop
bomb and it'll explode you can do the
very same thing in combat you can draw a
bomb and just leave it there and hit
people and it'll explode and take down
enemies you have all this mix of stuff
and then in because all these or your
your combat encounters very fast and it
grades you on how quickly do it how much
damage you take and then it gives you an
overall grading and then you get rewards
I love the way the a me controls as well
because as a wolf she's very quick she
wants which I really love galambos
around and that's why I and I think it's
just a very satisfying combat system
that encompasses so much you say it's
quick Oh
to me the combat is just broken up by
having to paint to me it's like that has
breaks up the combat and it's like I
constantly like feels that you're
constantly pausing to do something and
see I don't see it is breaking it up I
see it as like instigating something and
and then I just love the way that you
pause it and you have that direct effect
on it like on the Wii version and stuff
like I didn't even don't particularly
like the marshals I'm like weird I just
like drawing him in so I'm interested to
play this which version because I'm I
don't grow syphilis that we version she
sat on the tube going just bow down now
why art style oh I'm going a leveling up
yeah okay on a so watch out give me the
paper oh I'm gonna start painting my
argument well I mean the art style on a
commie is just beautiful as you can see
here but this little book that I bought
in Japan it's based on Japanese like ink
wash paintings and one of things I love
about economy is obviously the as you of
the Sun got ass and you're getting all
these or your brush strokes back so you
can interact with the world in different
ways one of the things you have to do is
you have to the demons are basically
sucking the life and all the nature in
the world and you have to put it back so
by putting a dot you can grow a tree or
you can just circle around a dead and
withered like bush or a tree and it'll
just spring back to life but and the
effects that they use are so beautiful
it's not even like style over substance
but it's one of those games where it's
art style and its content fit together
and it's music fit together so
cohesively that it just works it's a
good looking game Twilight Princess on
the other hand it's still a good looking
game it was an interesting time for
zelda games because the previous seller
was wind waker which did divide the
zelda fan base it went for a cartoony
cel-shaded aesthetic which I loved and
for me it was perfect
so when spoil a princess came about it
was revealed at and was III 2004 go back
and watch the reaction to link coming on
screen in this more realistic style of
graphics and art and the reaction is
crazy it felt like yeah it felt like
ocarina of time was back it's the
spiritual successor to that game so it
was kind of a big deal just in the art
style it was like oh this means business
this is a shift back towards the Zelda
that yeah we used to know Hyrule is
beautiful it's been taken over by the
Twilight Realm which itself is the art
style there is it
really weird it's like there's this
weird bloom effect that makes character
sort of glow and the Twilight has this
like pixelated blocky sort of effect
we're like portals open and then yeah I
couldn't link teleports between the
realms he like turned into these black
blobs and that is really cool and all
the monsters are very like creepy
looking and dark and it it's an
aesthetic that is different to any soda
game before I think the character
designs some of them are quite ugly but
in an endearing way like and it fits
into their characters like this is ugly
baby character place I posted the
picture this ugly baby on Twitter
because it's now my favorite Zelda
character because that paired with the
dialogue gets given just makes it
hilarious and it fits together in this
this style that is quite unique for
Twilight Princess it's very dark for his
older game and at the time that was
seriously cool I think the characters in
the comic just look beautiful marry just
very endearing I just think everything
about everything about economy is very
cohesive beautiful game also Orakei like
an 8 headed giant monster you have to
defeat a bunch of times well I've got
ugly goblins so people ugly goblins I've
got beautiful wolves yeah I think right
next up we have world the world of
Twilight Princess
yeah obviously Hyrule an iconic world
one that has been done before in Zelda
games this one is familiar they are
different it feels much more oppressive
than it has in previous games and
there's this darkness there's the
Twilight Realm there's these weird
freaky Twilight monsters dropping out of
the sky Cullen and these ones don't
Sparkle they and it is vast
it is it was bigger than any Zelda game
to date at that point I believe which
was incredible just being able to see
for miles I think I can ride a pony over
there it was amazing at the time not
just the size of it but what was in that
world was was crazy you had snow-peak
ruins this crazy
mansion in the tundra which was
different to any Zelda dungeon I'd seen
before you had a cannon that shot you to
a temple in the sky
you had the bridge of Elden which was
this massive bridge where he had an
iconic boss battle and that bridge is so
iconic that it became a Super Smash Bros
stage and it's it's a it's a beautiful
world that you love to explore every
nook and cranny and it's it's so filled
to the brim with detail and kooky
characters and weird enemies to fight
and just crazy dungeons to explore which
are some of the best in the series well
a world of economy both Nippon I mean
we've touched on like how beautiful it
is and how great it looks but I think I
love about Akane is that it's such a
huge vast game but it presents it to you
in a way that it's not overbearing and
overwhelming so you start out in a very
very small village and you kind of go
around do your bits in the village and
then you gradually get exposed to like a
big it's called Oh shouldn't you
plaintively that's a good humor but it's
still not too hugely becomes
overwhelming obviously owes a lot to
Zelda and it's basically the most Zelda
like game that doesn't say it sounds
pretty subtle like I think I love all
these pockets isn't it is there so
distinct and you know you can have this
beautiful like beautiful fields in
summertime there's animals going
everywhere and you're next to the coast
or you can be like climbing up a
mountain there's tons of different
variety in how the game looks the thing
I really love about economy is the way
that it's steeped with that Japanese
history and lore and myths and legends
and gods and it's just it kind of seeps
out of every pore of the game I just
love being in that world I just think
it's such a beautiful all-encompassing
world and every grain of it every part
of it it's just a very special Zelda
definite has that diversity to write it
it has like most Zelda games like a
desert area a water area there's a
fortress in the sky there's Twilight
Realm there's yeah like that we
it's no mansion they mentioned I think
for each one there are memorable moments
to be having that well yeah they're just
really good games and they're that both
really good yeah yeah I'll admit I'm
gonna pick this up on switch yeah like I
really wish that I princesses cuz I
playing it on your Wii U birthday my
fingers crossed I would play let us know
who you think won the debate by voting
in our poll on the top right corner of
the video or if you're everyone
gamespot.com by putting your thoughts
into the comment section below it were
your votes that decide who wins
so make yourselves heard right time for
this week's quick fire round a series of
dumb fun questions written by the rest
of the UK team let's see how will and
Lucy get on who would be the better pet
wolf link or Amaterasu well that's my
girl she can literally paint things into
existence using her tail I was pretty
cool could you be like she could fix
things I'm a plate of chicken nuggets no
but if your plate was broken its
scribble over it in the play we get this
link as a wolf could transform into a
human version of link and then play
Zelda with me you can't really have the
pet thing can you explain where Twilight
Princess sits in the Zelda chronology
that's easy
it's a spiritual successor to ocarina of
time and it's on the dark timeline
that's not answered the question I mean
there is a very complicated chart which
I don't have in front of me
I think Twilight Princess is on the one
offs ocarina who's more annoying issen
or Midna
no Midna hello turns into a beautiful
lady as not annoying to me I knew this
was coming
do your best wolf with a capital W how
I'm gonna try and do wolf howl from
Twilight Princess select the one that
summons the hawk God then you can't
avoid this
that's pretty good we're bound to get
your voice heard in our poll or in the
comments section below and tell us who
you think argue their case better and if
you enjoyed this episode of vs. make
sure to hit that subscribe button as
we'll have new episodes of the show
every Wednesday thanks for watching see
ya
[Music]
you